tu as et aux etats-unis toujours les
images de milliers de migrants à la
frontière sud du pays suscite la
polémique encore il s'agit notamment de
ressortissants haïtiens qui s'entassent
dans des villes frontalières près du
texas une crise migratoire qui provoque
énormément de critiques d'ailleurs
contre joe biden de la droite comme de
la gauche on trouve d'ailleurs notre
correspondant à new york thomas bonnin
coma avant soir alors comment réagir
justement la maison blanche face à cette
situation
et bien c'est une situation très
embarrassante pour la maison blanche ce
sujet parmi les sujets d'actualité les
plus discutés depuis le début de la
semaine et joe biden a été rattrapé lui
qui pensait plutôt consacré cette
semaine à la politique internationale
des états unis même lors de sa visite
ici à new york pour l'assemblée générale
des nations unies il a été interpellé
par des journalistes déjà sur cette
fameuse crise migratoire alors l'afflux
de migrants à la frontière sud des états
unis n'est pas véritablement un
phénomène nouveau cela fait maintenant
des semaines voire des mois que beaucoup
de migrants affluent en direction des
états unis mais ce qui est nouveau cette
fois c'est qu'il ya une arrivée massive
notamment de la part de ressortissants
haïtiens depuis ces derniers jours alors
selon certaines estimations il serait
14000 à être arrivé depuis le week end
dernier notamment près de la ville de
del rio dans l'état du texas à ce jour
là encore selon des estimations 2011
ressortissants haïtiens auraient été
expulsées malgré une politique
migratoire plus flexible de la part de
l'administration de joe biden alors
cette décision d'expulser des
ressortissant haïtien a provoqué
beaucoup de critiques de la part de
militants associatifs mais surtout elle
a provoqué la démission de l'émissaire
américain en haïti dans une lettre qu'il
a publié qu'il a adressé cette semaine
au secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken il se montre très virulent et il
explique les raisons de son départ
écoutez
je ne m'associerai pas la décision
inhumaine et contreproductif des états
unis d'expulser des milliers de réfugiés
i siens et d'immigrants illégaux en
haïti un pays où nos fonctionnaires sont
confinés dans des complexes sécurisé en
raison du danger que représentent les
gangs armés contrôlant la vie
quotidienne
alors à cette situation déjà très
délicate se sont ajoutés des images
impressionnantes des policiers à cheval
qui empêchent des migrants de traverser
le fleuve rio grande et la frontière
naturelle entre les etats-unis et le
mexique il ya notamment une photo d'un
garde frontières qui est donc à cheval
et qui attrape un homme par le tee shirt
et cette photo qui a beaucoup circulé
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment elle a
provoqué beaucoup d'émoi des images
elles saisissante qui ont nourri les
critiques pendant ces derniers jours si
bien que joe biden qui dit ce vendredi
en assumer la pleine responsabilité
affirme aussi que des sanctions vont
être prises contre ces officiers de
police écouter
juste c'est horrible de voir comme vous
l'avez vu de voir les gens traités ainsi
les chevaux en train de les écraser les
gens étant attachés c'est scandaleux je
vous le promets ces gens vont payer il y
aura une enquête il y aura des
conséquences s'il y aura des
conséquences mais c'est plus qu'un
embarras c'est dangereux c'est une
erreur ça envoie le mauvais message au
monde entier ce envoie le mauvais
message chez nous ce n'est tout
simplement pas qui nous sommes
et la décision a donc été prise pour le
moment de cesser l'utilisation de
policiers à cheval pour gérer l'afflux
donc de migrants près de la ville de del
rio sur la question de l'immigration
plus généralement l'administration de
joe biden joue les funambules parce que
d'un côté elle veut faire preuve de
fermeté et d'ailleurs elle a même
envisagé pendant un temps selon des
médias américains d'ouvrir un centre de
transit à guantanamo pour y héberger des
ressortissants haïtiens en attente d'une
décision sur leur possibilité ou non
d'entrer sur le territoire américain et
puis de l'autre côté à l'administration
de joe biden a permis à des milliers de
ressortissants haïtiens justement
d'entrer aux états unis alors quoi qu'il
arrive la gestion de cette crise
migratoire est très critiqué la droite
reproche à joe biden son laxisme et la
gauche condamne elle le traitement jugé
inhumain de ces réfugiés maintenant
beaucoup réclament que joe biden se
rendent sur place en personne alors que
cette crise migratoire justement un
impact non négligeable sur la popularité
du président merci beaucoup à vous tam
abonnés pour toutes à cette précision